Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von der ESA und dem DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die vierte Ausgabe in unserer Gesprächsreihe, wo wir versuchen, Einblicke zu liefern in die Welt der Raumfahrt, in die verschiedenen Teilbereiche, wie Projekte geplant werden, wie Projekte durchgeführt werden. Und nachdem wir uns beim letzten Mal so ausführlich über Raketen unterhalten haben und wie man denn vor allem den Sprung in den Raum konkret schafft und was alles dazu gehört, um das auch schaffen zu können, wollen wir uns heute ein bisschen dem Thema widmen, wie die Missionen, wenn sie denn dann mal begonnen haben, tatsächlich ins Rollen kommen und wie das Ganze überwacht und gesteuert wird. Das nennt man Operations und ich begrüße als Gesprächspartner für diese Reihe, Michel Dini. Michel, du bist auch hier, wir müssen auch wieder sagen, wo wir sind. Wir sind wieder in Darmstadt beim European Space Operations Center und da steckt es ja im Namen auch schon drin. Das ist eigentlich auch das Herz und die Kerntätigkeit hier in Darmstadt von dieser Niederlassung der ESA. Ja und Operations, das ist dein Gebiet, richtig?
Ja, das ist mein Gebiet seit fast 20 Jahren.
Wie bist du denn 20 Jahre, hajei, wie bist du denn dann dazugekommen?
Par am Mour, sagt man auf Französisch. Weil meine Frau einfach Deutsch ist oder war. Ich hab sie in Frankreich kennengelernt und ich wollte einfach hier in der Nähe eine Stelle finden. Ich hatte schon Interesse an Weltraum und war schon in einem vergleichbaren Gebiet in Frankreich. Berufstätig und ich habe so eine Stelle auf MeteoSat, diese Wetter-Satelliten damals bekommen. Und so hat es angefangen.
Aber inwiefern war Raumfahrt von Anfang an ein Thema? Also war das eher Zufall oder?
Eher Zufall. Ich hatte schon Interesse an komplexen Systemen und ich hatte ein bisschen mit Aeronautics oder mit Flugzeugen zu tun in Frankreich. Aber Raumfahrt war nur die logische Folge irgendwie.
Mit welcher Ausbildung bist du da herangekommen?
Also ich bin Ingenieur von einem Grand École in Frankreich, also einer Technischen Hochschule, École Centrale de Paris. Aber mein Fahrt war etwas ganz anderes. Bioengineering hat das mit Leben zu tun. Und vielleicht bin ich zurück zu diesem Interesse gekommen, zurückgekommen mit dem Mars heute. Das ist eine lange Geschichte.
Weil es da jetzt mittlerweile auch ums Leben geht, ja das stimmt. Aber grundsätzlich kann man sozusagen auch mit so einer Vorbildung hier Fuß fassen.
Ja, die meisten Leute hier sind Ingenieure oder Techniker und haben Interesse an Informatik, Radio und natürlich Space, also Weltraum oder Flugzeuge. Ein paar wollten schon Astronaut werden und wollen es noch. Aber ich glaube, das ist eine kleine Minderheit. Also es ist natürlich ein Traum von diesen Weltraumaktivitäten. Aber nicht unbedingt. Es kommen auch Leute, die nur einfach für technische, komplexe Sachen interessiert sind oder wissenschaftliche Aspekte natürlich.
Du bist ja auch ein schönes Beispiel für die Internationalität dieses Standorts. Wenn man hier in der Kantine umherläuft, da wird jede Sprache gesprochen, hat man so den Eindruck. Und Englisch ist hier generell die Umgangssprache. Das ist auch so im täglichen Geschäft so.
Ja, das ist die Arbeitssprache. Also offiziell bei der ESA muss man Englisch sprechen oder Französisch und am besten beides. Aber in der Praxis ist fast alles auf Englisch. In 20 Jahren habe ich nur ein oder zwei berufliche Meetings in Französisch gehalten. Es sei denn, mit Französischen Kollegen in meinem Team frische ich natürlich Französisch.
Ja klar, das ist ja auch selbstverständlich. Operations, darum soll es gehen, bezeichnet sozusagen all das, was dazugehört, um Satelliten in der Luft zu halten, also im Raum zu halten. Von Luft ist da ja nicht mehr so sehr viel übrig. Was umfasst denn das alles? Welche Bereiche?
Ja, das fängt an vielleicht mit einem Verständnis für die Mission, was man machen will und was man machen muss für unsere Kunden. Die Kunden sind also für wissenschaftliche Missionen, die sind Wissenschaftler und sie haben so Instrumente gebaut, die wir von der ESA auf unseren Plattformen, auf unseren Satelliten fliegen, um die Erde oder bis zu einem anderen Planet. Und wir müssen ihre Bedürfnisse in Kauf nehmen und alles planen, damit die wissenschaftliche Daten und so viele gute Daten wie möglich zurück zur Erde kommen und dann fließen über das Internet oder zu den Wissenschaftlern. Also das ist schon das Prinzip und von diesem Prinzip dann wird alles organisiert, damit alles reibungslos läuft.
Wir hatten ja hier auch in der zweiten Ausgabe schon diesen Bereich Missionsplanung mehr in den Mittelpunkt gestellt. Da ging es vor allem sozusagen erst mal um the big picture, weite Strecken über Brücken, wo fliegt man wirklich konkret lang, wie nutzt man quasi die Dynamik der anderen Planeten, um die richtige Route zu finden, um das entsprechende Ziel dann auch zu erreichen. Aber wenn ich jetzt hier höre Vorbereitung der Mission, dann ist es sozusagen die Vorbereitung von all dem ab dem Start, was dann anfällt, also die Übernahme der Daten und vor allem auch die Weiterleitung der Daten. Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ja, man muss vorbereiten und dann laufen lassen einen Betrieb. Das ist wie eine kleine Firma, je nach der Mission eine kleinere oder größere Firma. Und man hat für diesen Kunden sozusagen, für diesen Wissenschaftler die Aufgabe, ihren Request zu verwirklichen, was sie wollen, wann und was sie beobachten wollen, ob das compatible ist mit dem Stand des Satelliten zu jeglichen Zeitpunkt ist und dann zu machen mit Befehle an den Satelliten und die Ergebnisse, also die Daten zurück zu bekommen auf der Erde und weiter zu leiten.
Wie früh ist man denn da eingebunden? Also wann, wie viele Jahre vorher beginnt, vor dem Launch beginnt sozusagen diese Arbeit?
Die Vorbereitung fängt schon ein paar Jahre vor dem Launch, in meinem Fall vier Jahre, also je nachdem, acht bis drei Jahre vielleicht, je nach Komplexität der Mission und was zu machen ist. Aber vier, fünf Jahre ist typisch, wo ein SOM, ein Spacecraft Operations Manager, gelernt wird und der soll dann ein Team bauen, den Satelliten verstehen und der Satellit existiert noch nicht, der wird gerade gebaut von der Industrie. Und dieses Team muss bereit sein für den großen Tag, für das Launch natürlich und für alles, was danach kommt, also die Exploration, das Betrieb.
Space Operations Manager, das ist sozusagen dann derjenige, der die Vorbereitung leitet oder der dann auch das über die gesamte Zeit das Projekt leitet?
Also beides, also der ist dann am Anfang so ein bisschen wie ein Pfadfinder, würde ich sagen. Der muss sich in dem Jungle der Dokumente klarkommen und zuerst Dokumente von der Industrie bekommen, die den Satelliten beschreiben. Auch wenn dieser Satellit noch nicht fertig ist. Der muss gucken, dass die Kontrollsysteme fertig sein werden für den Launchtag. Und der muss das natürlich testen mit Simulatoren und manchmal auch mit Daten von den Satelliten, wenn der Satellit noch auf der Erde ist. Aber das kann kein Mensch allein machen und deswegen braucht er ein Team mit verschiedenen Spezialisten für On-Board-Computers und für Strom und für thermische Sachen und so weiter und so fort. Und diese Leute lernen einen Teil der Satelliten kennen und die arbeiten auch an diesen verschiedenen Tests von dem sogenannten Ground-Segment, also die verschiedenen Computers und Netzwerke, die wir hier benutzen, um die Befehle zu vorbereiten für den Satelliten und die Daten dann zu verarbeiten und weiter zu leiten, wenn sie irgendwo aus dem Satelliten kommen.
Ground-Segment bezeichnet quasi die Infrastruktur hier am Boden bei der ESOC, die notwendig ist, um den Satelliten zu steuern, zu leiten, zu überwachen, da hinunter zu laden. Also sozusagen alles, was hier vorgehalten wird, um das zu tun, ist das Ground-Segment.
Ja, alles was hier ist und alles auch was in den Bodenstationen ist. Und diese Bodenstationen sind um die Erde. Und wir haben große Antennen, für die planetarische Mission sind die größten Antennen von der ESA 35 Meter groß. Das ist wie Parabol-Schlüssel für das Fernsehen, nur viel größer und viel akkurater um ein Planet zu finden, der sehr, sehr weit ist zum Beispiel. Und wir haben auch ein 15 Meter Netzwerk für die Missionen, die nicht so weit sind, also für die Mission um die Erde.
Wie viel der 15 Meter an? Wie viel 35 Meter?
35 Meter haben wir zwei und wir bauen ein Drittel in Südamerika. Und warum haben wir zwei? Weil die Erde dreht sich um, um einen bestimmten Punkt im Himmel zu jeder Zeit hören zu können. Da muss man eine Bodenstation, also in unserem Fall in Australien, in Europa hier und dann in Südamerika haben und dann werden alle Ecken des Himmels bedeckt.
Man braucht eigentlich drei.
Ja.
Das heißt, derzeit hat man eigentlich zu wenig.
Ja, aber dafür kriegen wir Hilfe von unseren Kollegen in Amerika. Die DSN, Deep Space Network von der NASA, die haben drei sogenannte Komplexe. Also das sind eigentlich ein Set von Bodenstationen, die in drei Orten der Welt sind. In Canberra haben sie mehrere Antennen, in Australien, in Robledo bei Madrid und in Goldstone in Kalifornien. Und natürlich in unserem Fall bekommen wir mehr Hilfe vom Goldstone, weil wir noch keine amerikanische Antenne haben. Aber die in Malargue in Argentinien ist für 2012 geplant und die Arbeit haben schon angefangen.
Das heißt, dann ist das ESA-Netzwerk sozusagen erst komplett?
Genau.
Aber genauso wird ja auch die ESA-Infrastruktur für Missionen der NASA bereitgestellt, wenn der Bedarf da ist.
Wir machen auch mit den Agreements und wir können Missionen unterstützen, je nach Agreement. Und wir haben das schon gemacht, entweder für Launches oder für besondere Gelegenheiten wie Ankunft von einem Planeten zum Beispiel.
Ja, wenn man mal richtig viel Datenkapazität, Empfangskapazität braucht.
Und wenn man...
Ausfallsicherheit.
Ja, nicht nur die Kapazität auch. Man braucht hier für alles ein sogenanntes Backup. Also wir haben von allem zwei für kritische Phasen. Und das heißt zwei Computer, zwei Bodenstationen in demselben Gebiet etc. Wenn es läuft für die normale, für die Routine-Mission, dann können wir das zweite, das Backup so entweder zurückgeben oder benutzen nur für Simulationen, je nachdem, weil es so weniger kostet. Aber für die kritischen Phasen, wie ein Launch oder Ankunft von einem Planeten, dann gibt es alles, alles ist verdoppelt und ist in Warm-Standby. Das heißt, es ist bereit anzuspringen, wenn das Hauptobjekt nicht funktioniert. Hauptanthenakomputer, alles.
Also das gilt jetzt sowohl für die Bodenstationen als auch für das Ground-Segment hier.
Ja, für die Computer, für die Netzwerke, alles, alles ist verdoppelt. Und eigentlich, das ist ein Spiegelbild von den Satelliten. Weil an Bord der Satelliten ist auch alles oder fast alles verdoppelt. Nur die Antenne, die größte Antenne an einem Satelliten, es ist nicht Fleisch vor zwei, aber alle Computer, Netzwerke, Treibwerke, alles oder fast alles ist verdoppelt. Warum? Weil wenn irgendwas kaputt geht, gibt es dann doch eine zweite Chance.
Ach, vollziehbar. Der Satellit ist meistens auch verdoppelt. Also es gibt ja dann auch immer noch ein Modell, was dann auf dem Boden ist.
Ja, also das ist ein Entwicklungsprozess. Also man baut zuerst ein sogenannter Engineering Model mit Komponenten, die nicht so hochwertig sind, wie die fliegen sollen, aber manchmal doch. Und so können die Ingenieur und Techniker sehen, ob alles zusammen passt, ob alles zusammen funktioniert, also von Platz her, von elektrischer Kompatibilität her und so weiter. Und dann oder parallel schon bauen sie das Flight Model. Und Flight Model ist der Satellit, der fliegt. Nur die Missionen, die nicht so viel Geld zur Verfügung haben, die können sich das nicht leisten. Und das heißt, sie machen nur ein sogenanntes Proto Flight Model. Und das ist ein Prototyp, das wird auf dem Boden so testiert. Und das wird ins Hand geschickt und das funktioniert auch.
Aber das Engineering Model, das ist dann sozusagen auch sehr hilfreich. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn jetzt eine kritische Situation aufgetreten ist, irgendeine schwere Fehlfunktion und auch das Backup funktioniert nicht und man muss jetzt überlegen, wie man der Situation her wird, dass man dann am Engineering Model versucht, auf neue Ideen zu kommen.
Genau, du hast mich ins Herz getroffen. Heute war ich ein bisschen spät, weil wir hatten ein kleines Problem von dem Speicher, von dem Mass-Memory an Bord Mars Express. Und nichts Schlimmes, aber wir wollen was machen und wir möchten natürlich das zuerst testen auf dem Boden. Aber Mars Express ist so ein Protoflight-Model. Es gibt keinen Engineering Model auf dem Boden. Also wir müssen uns wagen, die Recovery Procedure, die wir in ein paar Tagen benutzen werden. Wir müssen das auf dem echten Satelliten am Mars machen. Es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit. Unsere Kollegen von Rosetta, die haben hier in der ESOC einen Engineering Model, der elektrisch ganz genau ist, wie der Rosetta, der fliegt. Und wenn sie dasselbe Problem hätten, könnten sie das schon hier machen auf der Erde. Das wäre schöner.
Mars Express, wie der Name schon sagt, das ist das Äquivalent zur Erdbeobachtung. Das ist die Mars-Beobachtung, die Mission, die versucht, den Mars zu kartografieren, bzw. das auch schon seit einiger Zeit sehr erfolgreich tut. Rosetta hatten wir hier auch in den Gesprächen schon angesprochen, insbesondere bei der Missionsplanung. Das ist halt die Raumsonde, die sich auf die Spur der Asteroiden macht. Bevor wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen detaillierter bei Mars Express einsteigen, würde ich gerne noch einen kurzen Moment auf dem Boden bleiben und vor allem auch uns mal so langsam rantasten an den Moment, wo es dann wirklich auch in die heiße Phase eintritt und wo das Projekt eigentlich auch wirklich beginnt. Wir haben jetzt gehört, es gibt eine Vorbereitungsphase. Das ist ja auch selbstverständlich. Man muss es irgendwie planen. Man muss vor allem mit den Kunden, den anderen Wissenschaftlern vorher schon abstimmen, wie es denn dann eben alles laufen soll, weil die ja auch in der Lage sein müssen, die Daten dann entsprechend zu übernehmen. Mit wie vielen anderen, also Gruppen, Kunden, Wissenschaftlern hat man es denn so üblicherweise zu tun? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Sind das drei oder vier oder fünf oder 50 oder hunderte? Mit wie vielen Leuten muss man da quasi eine Schnittstelle aufbauen?
Okay, die Wissenschaftler sind zum Glück nicht nur direkt zu uns im Kontakt, aber über einen Project Scientist, also einen Leiter der wissenschaftlichen Gruppe. Und wir haben Meetings regelmäßig vor und nach dem Launchingsall. Aber das ist konzeptuell eine Gruppe, aber jeder Instrument hat seine Schwierigkeiten oder seine Eigenschaften. An Bord eines typischen Satelliten sind das zwei bis zehn Instrumente, also typisch fünf, sechs. Und man hat Kontakt zu zu allen Leuten in dieser Gruppe. Und die Kontakte können sehr gut sein, aber am Anfang ist jeder Anfang schwierig. Also das muss man doch auch zusammen mit regeln und man findet Kompromisse.
Das heißt, das Ganze ist auch beileibe nicht nur eine technische Aufgabe und wissenschaftliche Aufgabe, sondern man muss auch eine ganze Menge soziale Aktivität entfalten, um so ein Projekt zusammenzuhalten.
Ja, ein bisschen schon. Aber es ist auch eine sehr interessante Seite der Arbeit. Man kann nicht sagen, ja, ja, ich bleibe in meinem Büro und lese durch alle Dokumente, bis ich den Satelliten völlig verstehe und dann wird alles reibungslos funktionieren. Das geht nicht. Das geht nicht mit den Kunden, also den Wissenschaftlern. Das geht auch nicht mit den Teammitgliedern, weil man muss auch mit Leuten reden. Und besonders in unserem Umgebung hat man auch zu tun, nicht nur mit Stress von diesen einmaligen Ereignissen. Ein Lohnstumars hat das gemacht 2003 und wird wieder machen 2016 hoffentlich. Aber das passiert in einem beruflichen Leben einmal oder zweimal. Und für die Wissenschaftler, das ist auch so. Das ist auch sehr gestresst. Und man hat mit Problemen eine Art zu tun. Und man muss doch damit leben. Und manchmal auch zu sehr ungünstigen Zeiten. Wie wir landen oder wir starten ins Aal. Am Tag, wo die Flugdynamik das will und braucht. Nicht an dem Tag, wo es für uns bequem ist.
Ja, da ist man dann sozusagen auch ganz nur ein kleiner Teil des Universums und muss den Naturgesetzen auch gehorchen. Ja, wenn man jetzt mal schaut, was jetzt nötig ist. Also was ich verstanden habe, ist ganz klar, man muss sich natürlich ein Team zusammensuchen. Man muss sich die richtigen Leute suchen. Das dauert wahrscheinlich eine Weile. Und man muss vor allem mit allen beteiligten Projektpartnern da zusammenarbeiten und sich über Prozeduren, Datenformate etc. Wenn das jetzt alles getan ist und wenn der Launch Day näher rückt, was hat sich dann am Ende alles an konkreter Infrastruktur hier zusammengefunden? Also wenn ich es richtig verstehe, es gibt für jede Mission hier einen eigenen Kontrollraum. Beziehungsweise den gibt es dann auch doppelt?
Also fast. Also es gibt für den Launch, gibt es einen Hauptkontrollraum und das wird von allen Missionen benutzt, weil Launches gibt es nur so ein paar Mal im Jahr. Das kann man so regeln, obwohl es gibt auch einen Backup-Hauptkontrollraum, der viel kleiner ist, aber man könnte prinzipiell von hier aus zwei Launches gleichzeitig machen. Und der zukünftige Hauptkontrollraum wird auch so arrangiert, dass man mehrere Satelliten gleichzeitig starten kann.
Also wird gerade ein neuer gebaut?
Ja, das wird ein neuer, aber man hat das schon gemacht. Mit den Clusters, also mit Cluster 1, das waren vier gleichzeitig. Leider gab es dann Raketenprobleme, die sind verloren gegangen. Aber mit Cluster 2, vier Jahre später, das waren zwei gleichzeitig. Und mit Herschel Planck letztes Jahr, das waren auch zwei gleichzeitig. Also das können wir schon machen. Und zwei, die verwandt sind. Aber wir haben auch einen anderen Hauptkontrollraum. Also wir könnten auch prinzipiell zwei völlig unterschiedliche Missionen gleichzeitig starten.
Was ist in diesem Kontrollraum für den Launch alles zusammen?
Im Kontrollraum sieht man Computer, wie man zu den Satelliten sprechen kann und wie man die Daten empfängt und decodiert und liest und versteht und darstellt mit Grafiken und so weiter. Und Kommunikation, also Netzwerke zu den Bodenstationen. Und auch Voice-Communications mit sogenannten Loops, also so direkte Kontakt mit, das ist kein Telefon, das ist so eine private Linie, die uns mit den Bodenstationen verbinden. Und so kann man sich vorstellen, das ist wie ein Terminal oder in einem Flughafen. Aber in diesem Raum, was am wichtigsten ist, das sind nicht nur die Computer, das sind auch die Menschen. Und die Menschen werden streng organisiert, besonders für die Launch-Perioden. Also es gibt nicht nur der Spacecraft Operations Manager, der eine besondere Rolle hat, das ist auch ein Flugdirektor. Der ist der große Boss in dem Raum. Es ist eine Bodenstation-Kontaktperson, der direkt mit den Bodenstationen spricht. Und die verschiedenen Ingenieure, die haben auch ihre eigene Rolle. Und die müssen und sollen auf einen besonderen Gebiet konzentrieren. Die dürfen auch mithelfen auf andere Probleme. Aber jeder hat eine sehr strikt definierte Rolle am Anfang. Und das wird natürlich, das kommt nicht von selbst, das wird geübt, die letzten sechs Monate vor dem Launch in einem Simulation Program. Also wir machen zweimal in der Woche eine Simulation, wo jeder spielt seine eigene Rolle. Das kann man eher zum Theater vergleichen. Man muss einfach viele Proben machen, bis es alles reibungslos funktioniert.
Und das macht man auch in dem Raum?
Das macht man schon in dem Raum, also nicht mit der Kleidung von dem Tag, aber fast. Und auch mit Helm und Mikrofon und auch mit den Prozeduren, die sehr oft noch nicht perfekt sind, aber die werden auch in den letzten paar Monaten verbessert von dieser Simulation. Und hinter den Computerbildschirmen ist kein Satelliten, aber ein Simulator und ein Simulation Officer, also eine Person, die entscheidet, ob heute alles normal ist oder ob heute eine Panne kommt. Und alles, also am Anfang ist das alles normal.
Ohne das jemandem zu sagen.
Und in jedem Fall dürfen wir nicht wissen im Voraus, welche Panne es ist. Und wir üben eigentlich, das ist alles auch verdoppelt, zwei Teams, Team A und Team B. Und wenn Team A eine Simulation hat, darf Team B gute oder schlechte Rate an dem Simulation Officer geben, damit die anderen Probleme, also schlimme Probleme, erfahren dürfen.
Das heißt, das Team für den Launch-Day wird auch doppelt ausgelegt?
Ja, weil wir für ein paar Tage 24 Stunden am Tag arbeiten müssen. Kein Mensch macht das, aber zwei Teams zu zwölf Stunden für jedes Team.
Und es kann natürlich auch mal jemand krank werden.
Ja, also wir haben auch ein bisschen, aber krank werden ist nicht angesagt. Also man hat auch gehört von Special Operations Manager, die verboten haben, ihre Leute Ski zu fahren, zum Beispiel ein paar Monate vor dem Launch. Aber man kann auch in der eigenen Küche so einfach rutschen. Und das ist auch passiert und das war auch lustig.
Okay, alles doppelt. Das heißt, bevor es wirklich zum Launch-Day kommt, ist im Prinzip der Launch in diesem Kontrollraum mehrere Male über einen Zeitraum von mehreren Monaten mehr oder weniger genauso, wie er dann abläuft, komplett simuliert worden mit unterschiedlichen Fehlerereignissen oder auch mal mit gar keinem.
Ja, ganz genau. Also wenn es kommt zu dem echten Tag, prinzipiell soll alles sein, wie es war bei dem Simulator. Und eigentlich in meinem Fall, also für Mars Express, das war so. Also um den Zeitpunkt 1945 waren da die Daten, genau wie sie waren auf dem Simulator. Und der Satellit war in seinem eigenen Separation Sequence, wie er sich von der Rakete abhängt sozusagen. Der war genau zu dem Punkt, wo wir ihn erwartet hatten.
Ja, vielleicht kommen wir dann mal so langsam in diese Richtung. Wir hatten ja hier im letzten Gespräch uns ausführlich darüber unterhalten, was sozusagen jetzt raketentechnisch erforderlich ist, um die Nutzlast überhaupt erst mal abzusetzen. Aber das ist ja dann auch sozusagen der Zeitpunkt, wo das eigentliche Betreuungsteam, eigentlich Operations-Team übernimmt. Oder ist der Satellit vorher schon in irgendeiner Form verbunden?
Für die letzte paar Stunden vor dem Launch bekommt man generell Telemetrie, also Daten von den Satelliten über die Bodennetzwerke. Und man kann so prüfen, dass alles gut läuft. Aber wir haben dafür keinen Anfluss darauf. Das geht einfach, wie es gehen soll. Die Raketenleute und die Leute von dem Projekt, also die Leute, die den Satelliten gebaut haben, von der Industrie haben ihre Leute bei dem Launch Site, also entweder in Kourou oder Baikonur und so weiter. Und diese Leute könnten prinzipiell sagen, oh, irgendwas ist falsch, wir müssen bis morgen warten. Aber in dieser Launch-Phase kommt alles von den Raketenleuten. Und wenn ein Launch verschoben wird, das ist weil ein kleines Fehler aus dem Computer von der Rakete kommt. Generell kein richtiges Fehler, aber man will sicher sein, weil Rakete, das kann man nur einmal probieren. Man kann eine Rakete nicht probieren. Man hat nur einen Schuss frei, das stimmt.
Aber in dem Moment, wo dann die Rakete tatsächlich auf dem Launchpad steht und ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt gibt es dann auch keine Kommunikation mehr mit dem Satelliten?
Ja, je nachdem, wenn dieser Schnu kaputt geht, bis zum Launch.
Welcher Schnu ist das?
Also so eine elektrische Verbindung zu dem Satelliten. Das könnte bis sehr kurz vor dem Launch, vielleicht eine Stunde, oder so, kann man noch Telemetrie empfangen. Dann ist natürlich so ein Blackout, was sehr wichtig ist für die Raketenleute. Ist für uns auch sehr wichtig, aber nach dem Launch ist generell so ein kleines Fest, oder ein kleines was zum Essen in der Kantine und man muss ja so schön fit sein für wenn unsere Arbeit anfängt. Das ist so ungefähr eine Stunde bis zwei Stunden je nach dem Lohn zu einer Laufbahn, wenn der Satelliten wird von der Rakete abgetrennt. Und dann müssen wir anspringen und prüfen, dass alles läuft wie geplant. Alles ist am Anfang automatisch. Aber falls irgendwas nicht gut funktioniert hat, dann können wir auch Befehle schicken, sobald der Satelliten von der Rakete abgetrennt ist. Zum Beispiel, wenn die Solargeneratoren, diese Solarpanels sich nicht richtig ausgeklappt haben, dann können wir das wieder probieren mit Kommandos, mit Befehlen. Das wird sehr oft in Simulationen geübt, weil das ist natürlich lebenswichtig für den Satelliten. Solargenerator, kein Strom, keine Mission, tschüss. Aber das sind auch sehr einfache Systeme, das funktioniert normalerweise.
Aber kurz noch mal bei dem Launch zu bleiben. Das heißt, Rakete startet, erste Stufe verbrennt, dann startet die Oberstufe, die den Satelliten überhaupt erst in den interessanten Bereich bringt. Jetzt hängt es natürlich sehr davon ab, von was für einer Mission wir hier reden, ob das jetzt Erdbeobachtung ist oder ob man tatsächlich eine Mission hat, wo es darum geht, die Erde zu verlassen. Aber irgendwann geht ja sozusagen der Deckel auf, also die eigentliche Umhüllung wird abgesprengt, dann liegt der Satellit quasi nackt vorne an, wird aber noch ein bisschen rausgeschoben. Ab wann fängt, wann wird dieser Satellit aktiviert, wodurch wird der überhaupt aktiviert, wann hört man das erste Mal was?
Also aktiviert, es passiert schon was, also die sogenannte Separation Sequence hat mehrere Stufen und die funktionieren schon automatisch ohne Bodenaktion. Und wenn die Abtrennung von der letzten Stufe passiert, da können, da werden die Radio eingeschaltet und wir bekommen, wir empfangen einfach das Signal und können die Telemetrie checken.
Aber läuft der Satellit schon die ganze Zeit während des Launches oder wird er erst eingeschaltet, wenn er oben ist?
Nee, der ist angeschaltet vor dem Launch und er läuft auf Batteries in einem Stand-by-Modus, das sind nur so Konnektoren, die von ihren Abtrennungen dann die Weiterfolge von dieser Separation Sequence auslösen.
Das heißt, mit der Separation Sequence geht der Satellit aus diesem Stand-by-Modus heraus? Ja, und dann fängt er sofort an erst mal zu funken?
Ja, erst mal die Strom zu generieren, also erst mal die Solaregeneratoren auszufalten.
Ach so, das muss zuerst erfolgen, bevor man überhaupt irgendwie Funkkontakt hat.
Ja, weil man braucht, und dann wird Funkkontakt etabliert und das sieht man, ob das klappt.
Aber wenn man mit den Satelliten reden muss, um ihm dabei zu helfen, die Dinge auszuklappen, dann muss ja auch schon Funk existieren.
Ja, ich weiß nicht mehr, in welchen Orden das war, aber das ist sehr kurz danach oder davor.
Okay, aber er könnte auch ohne Solarstrom auf jeden Fall noch eine Weile mit den Batterien funken. Okay, dann sind die Solarpanele ausgeklappt und dann geht es richtig los. Die ganze Kommunikation geht jetzt über diese großen Bodenstationen.
Ja. Und dann sollen wir...
Was hat das so für Laufzeiten? Also wie viel Verzögerung ist jetzt bei der Kommunikation mit dem Satelliten? Wie schnell erreichen Informationen vom Satelliten das Kontrollzentrum und wie schnell gehen Kommandos dahin?
Am Anfang, das ist eine Sekunde, weil der Satelliten gar nicht weit ist und die Bodenkontakte, die laufen so fast instant.
Ja, aber die Verbindung zu den Bodenstationen, was für Wege nimmt das?
Das ist nur eine Fraktion, eine Sekunde, das ist nichts.
Ja, aber ich meine, wie sind die miteinander verbunden? Wie ist man mit diesen Bodenstationen tatsächlich verbunden?
Mit Lease Lines, mit Verbindungen, privaten Verbindungen. Man zahlt dafür, das ist nicht mit Internet natürlich. Das kostet was. Aber da haben wir hier nicht nur ein Kontrollzentrum, aber ein Netzwertszentrum. Dafür sind Wide-Area-Network-Connections gebaut. Das hat sich auch sehr viel verbessert in den letzten paar Jahren. Jetzt benutzen wir 1,5 Megabits pro Sekunde oder 3 Megabits pro Sekunde Verbindungen.
Das sind in der Regel Sehkabel wahrscheinlich.
Ja. Auf diese Kabel gibt es auch Maintenance. Aber das wird von dem Provider gemacht. Das ist sehr selten. Es ist auch letztlich passiert, dass ein Provider etwas unter dem Meer ändern sollte. Irgendetwas war falsch und der hatte so Down Time. Das passiert sehr selten. Sie haben auch sehr viel Redundancy, sehr viele Back-ups. Sonst würde keine interkontinentale Kommunikation funktionieren.
Aber es gibt jetzt keine Funkverbindung zu der Bodenstation, sondern man basiert ausschließlich auf Erdleitung.
Ja, es gab ein paar Ausnahmen, aber für unsere normale Mission ist es mit Kabel.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt relativ fix und schnell mit dem Satelliten reden. Der klappt jetzt seine Sonnenflügel aus und hat dann auch sofort den Strom, den er braucht. Jetzt ist er ja noch nicht unbedingt da, wo er hin muss.
Nee, und er ist gar nicht so fahrbar. Also er ist noch nicht fertig. Man muss jetzt ein paar Stufen mehr machen, wo der Boden, also wir, was zu tun haben. Der Satelliten zum Beispiel hat sogenannte Reaction Wheels. Und am Anfang sind sie einfach aus. Und der wird ausgerichtet nur mit kleinen Treibraketen, die Thrusters. Man muss einfach diese Reaction Wheels benutzen, prüfen und dann die Reaction Wheels. Das sind Räder, schwere Räder, die sind in dem Satelliten. Und wenn man an diesen Rädern Strom gibt, die drehen sich schneller und der Satelliten dreht sich in die andere Richtung. Konservation des Momentums.
Das heißt, damit kann der sozusagen sich drehen und wenden?
Sich drehen und wenden Richtung Erde oder danach Richtung Ziel, das es beobachtet muss. Und das will man nicht mit ganz kleinen Triebraketten machen, weil das kostet Treibstoff. Und Treibstoff kann man nicht ersetzen, nicht nachdanken. Im Ali ist von der Tankstelle ein permanenter Streik. Also man muss nur erneuerbare Energie benutzen, und zwar Strom von den Solargeneratoren. Und deswegen hat man diese Räder.
Verstehe. Jetzt ist es natürlich ein großer Unterschied, je nachdem, was für eine Mission überhaupt gefahren wird. In welche Arten von Missionen werden denn jetzt grundsätzlich erstmal unterschieden? Was gibt es denn da so für Familien?
Also bei uns, bei der ESA macht man prinzipiell nur neue Missionen. Also wir sind auch Pfadfinder für neue Technologie, neue Ziele und so weiter. Und wir haben hier drei Familien von Missionen. Erdbeobachtung, wie Wetter-Satelliten oder Klimaforschung und so weiter. Und auch Sicherheit, aber das ist eine nächste Stufe. Also das ist die erste Familie. Die zweite Familie ist Astronomie. Also warum Teleskopen im All fliegen. Weil über die Atmosphäre kriegt man andere Teile des Spektrums, das man auf der Erde durch die Atmosphäre nicht empfangen kann. Also wie zum Beispiel Hubble oder Herschel Planck und so weiter. Oder XMM im X-Ray-Bereich. Herschel im Infrarot. Hubble meistens in Invisible. Hubble ist eine Kooperation, aber ja amerikanische Satelliten. Wir haben auch ein Gamma-Ray-Satelliten, integral. Das sind die astronomischen Missionen und die gucken in Richtung der Sternen. Wir machen auch Astronometrie-Missionen, also die die Sternen einfach messen und wo sie sind und wieviel sie sind. Die nächste heißt Gaia und soll sehr akkurat sein, aber soll in zwei Jahren ins All gestartet werden. Und die dritte Familie, woher ich komme, ist die interplanetarische Familie mit Missionen zu Planeten wie Venus Express und Mars Express und Missionen zu Asteroiden und Kometen wie Rosetta.
Was meinst du mit woher ich komme? Bist du doch nicht aus Frankreich?
Manchmal fragen die Leute, auf welchem Planeten wohnst du denn? Meinem Gedanken bin ich manchmal sehr weit von hier. Ganz normal, bodenständig muss man bei den Operationen sein. Die Idee von Rocket Scientist und von Leuten, die immer den Kopf in den Sternen haben, das braucht man. Die sind wahrscheinlich eher auf der wissenschaftlichen Seite. Aber die Leute, die hier arbeiten, der Operations, die schätzen alle sehr bodenständig, sehr praktisch, sehr rationell. Und das braucht man für unsere Arbeit. Und die Leute, die mehr konzeptuell sind, mehr träume vielleicht sind, ich glaube, die würden sich hier langweilen.
Das sind unterschiedliche Fähigkeiten, die man natürlich haben muss. Auf der einen Seite braucht man Leute, die sich einfach auch mal verrückte Wege und neue Ansätze ausdenken. Auf der anderen Seite braucht man Leute, die einfach auch mit den harten Realitäten klarkommen.
Und wenn man einen Befehl zu dem Satelliten geschickt hat, das war's, man kann nichts ändern. Das Kommando fliegt. Man kann es nicht überholen, zurückkriegen, das war's. Deswegen ist es hier sehr wichtig, dass die Leute, die Operationen machen, sehr praktisch und irgendwie einfach sind.
Ja, eine dieser interplanetarischen Missionen haben wir ja schon erwähnt. Das ist Mars Express, auch eines der bekannteren Projekte, wie natürlich immer die interplanetaren Sachen natürlich sehr viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit erzeugen. Aber es ist nicht unangemessen, das hierzu erwähnen, weil du bist ja unter anderem auch für Mars Express zuständig. Was ist da genau deine Rolle?
Also Spacecraft Operations Manager, also jetzt bin ich ja Betriebsmanager, so sagen wir mal, von diesem kleinen Einheit von Leuten, die die wissenschaftliche Planung von dem Wissenschaftszentrum bekommen, alles zusammenbringen mit den Möglichkeiten des Satelliten und sagen, ja das können wir machen, das können wir nicht, bitte ein bisschen weniger Strom fordern und so weiter. Und dann, das passiert so ein paar Wochen vor der geplanten Aktivität, und dann ein paar Tage vor dieser Beobachtung, dann werden die Kommandos hochgeschickt, also zum Mars, und dann bekommt man die Daten ein paar Stunden oder Tage nach der Beobachtung. Und man muss auch ständig natürlich überprüfen, dass der Satelliten macht, was er machen sollte, dass kein Fehler angetreten ist und so weiter.
Das ist ja dann schon sozusagen, das ist ja dann schon so Teil 2. Ich meine, bisher waren wir ja jetzt gerade mal so beim Launch. Das Ding ist ja sozusagen noch gar nicht auf dem richtigen Weg. Wenn wir uns jetzt vielleicht mal an diesem Beispiel von Mars Express festklammern und nochmal kurz zurückgehen auf diesen Moment, wo Satellit ist an der Stelle gar nicht die richtige Bezeichnung, Raumsonde. Andererseits wird er ja wieder zum Satelliten. Wie nennt man dann das Objekt, wenn sozusagen Raumsonde und Satelliten einem ist?
Ja, Raumsonde wahrscheinlich.
Ich weiß nicht, wovon spricht man?
Hier sagt man Satelliten, also umgänglich. Und ja, wie ist so? Spatial? Space wie High Call. Raumschiff. Ja, ist ein Raumschiff. Kleines schwarzes Raumschiff.
Nennen wir es Raumschiff. Also, jetzt ist das Ding ausgesetzt worden. Solarpanele ausgeklappt, Strom ist da, alles super. Bodenstation, Funk und die Seekabel liegen auch alle noch an der richtigen Stelle. Das ist ja so der kritische Moment, der eigentlich schon mal über einen ganz wichtigen Punkt, nämlich den Start, weitgehend entscheidet, oder? Ist das nicht so, ich hatte hier die Gelegenheit, den Start von dem Kryosat 2 mitzubekommen und so mein Blick ins Kontrollzentrum. Der eigentliche Start hat hier noch keinen interessiert, aber erst in dem Moment, als man dann auch wirklich das Signal empfangen hat, war natürlich großes Aufatmen. Das ist jetzt beim Kryosat nochmal eine besondere Geschichte, weil es einen ersten gab, der durch einen Systemfehler erst gar nicht in den Orbit gekommen ist. Aber das war dann sozusagen der große Moment der Erleichterung. Ist das dann schon, ist das immer so?
Ja, in meinem Fall, das war so. Wenn ich zu dem vorgesehenen Zeitpunkt die Telemetrie gesehen habe, also so drei Sekunden nach dem vorgesehenen Punkt, dann hab ich einfach gesagt, I can't believe it. Ich kann es nicht glauben. Das war einfach da. Das war eine große Erleichterung, dass es so pünktlich war und dass alles schon bei der richtigen Etappe in der Separation Sequence war und dass alles klappte.
Das heißt, die große Erleichterung kommt eigentlich ganz zum Anfang, wo die Arbeit erst losgeht. Dann geht es ja erst los.
Ja, und dann geht die Arbeit los und dann nach ein paar Stunden oder Tage ist es vielleicht mal nicht so erleichtert. Je nachdem, weil das zweite Teil, also in der Falle eines planetarischen Missions, das ist nicht, wie es an den Planeten passiert. Das ist, wie man geht oder fliegt von der Erde bis zu den Planeten. Und das kann sehr schwierig sein. Umlaufbahn ist natürlich bekannt und Manövern muss man machen und gehen prinzipiell ziemlich gut. Aber diese ersten sieben Monate im All, wo jeder Tag der Satelliten weiter von der Erde ist und die Zeiten für die Kommunikation größer werden, das kann sehr, sehr stressig sein. Besonders bei der ersten Sonde einer Familie. Und das war der Fall für Mars Express. Da war der erste seiner Reihenfolge. Die Leute auf dem Boden hatten gut gearbeitet. Aber keine ähnliche Sonde wurde geflogen.
Was war jetzt so anders an der Sonde?
Das war eigentlich die erste interplanetärische Mission der ESA. Das war ein wiederbenutzter Design von Rosetta. Am Anfang sollte Rosetta früher fliegen als Mars Express. Anfang 2003 hätte Rosetta fliegen sollen. Mars Express Juni 2003. Ende 2002 war ein Problem auf Ariane 5. 3 Rakete für Rosetta in der stärksten Variante gefunden worden. Sie haben gesagt, wir können nicht so früh Rosetta ins Aal. Wir trauen uns nicht. Dann Mars Express, der kleine Bruder oder die kleine Schwester, war plötzlich vorne. Und war auch gemacht worden ziemlich schnell, wie vorher gesagt, ohne Engineering Model. Mit viel, viel weniger Geld als Rosetta, weil bei uns gibt es auch andere Familien, wie die Cornerstones Mission, die große und die Middle Class und auch die Flexi Mission, wie Mars Express. Wenig Geld und große Ambitionen, das geht. Am Anfang war das ziemlich schwer. Dann haben wir in all durch Tiefing Problems, also Probleme der Kindheit eines Systems, erfahren müssen. Ein paar Sachen waren einfach nicht genug oder lang genug getestet worden auf dem Boden.
Was denn zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel diese Speicher, die Mass Memory hatten am Anfang ziemlich viele Probleme und nach mehreren neuen Softwareversionen, weil wenn irgendwas fliegt, das Einzige, das geändert werden kann, ist die Software. Dann hat es endlich gut funktioniert, aber das hat ein paar Monaten gedauert, bis die richtigen Fehler gefunden worden sind. Was am Anfang, also jetzt ein paar Stunden nach dem Launch, gar nicht funktioniert hat, sind die Star-Trackers. Star-Trackers sind diese Kameras, die zu den Sternen gucken und die Konstellationen erkennen. Dann wissen sie, in welche Richtung der Satelliten sich befindet.
So wie das im Prinzip die Seefahrer früher mit dem Sechstanten gemacht haben.
Genau, das ist das Sechstantenbord Mars Express, das funktioniert ganz gut. Natürlich muss man nicht in Richtung der Sonne gucken. Das war auch gut vorgesehen. Am Anfang wollten beide Star-Trackers keine Konstellation erkennen. Die Ursache war wahrscheinlich, dass von der Sonne, der weit weg war, 60 Grad oder so, eine kleine Reflexion durch den Sonnenschutz zu der Optik gehen könnte. Und da war der Star-Tracker blind. Und was haben die Leute von der Industrie gedacht? Ja, wenn wir diese Parasiten-Licht so ausblenden, dann kann der Star-Tracker wieder funktionieren. Und das haben sie gemacht mit so einem Patch, also einem kleinen Software-Komponent. Das haben wir zu dem Satelliten geschickt und wir haben das genannt, die Sonnenbrille-Software. Wenn du dein Auto fährst in die Richtung Sonne, dann ist es besser, dass du Sonnenbrille hast, weil die Dinge siehst du ein bisschen weniger gut, aber trotzdem besser als ohne Sonnenbrille. Und genau das haben wir hochgeladen und das hat funktioniert. Und das ohne Star Trekker ist ein Satelliten blind. Der muss wissen, in welche Richtung er guckt, besonders wenn er sehr weit von der Erde ist. Weil von Mars aus gesehen, die Erde ist ein kleiner blauer Punkt. Sehr, sehr klein. Es gibt keinen Sensor für die Erde, wenn man 400 Millionen Kilometer ist. Die Erde ist ein Punkt wie alle anderen Punkte. Wenn man in der Erdumlaufbahn ist, kann man so Earth-Sensors, also Erdensensoren, haben an Bord. Aber soweit, die helfen nicht. Man kann nur die Sonne erkennen und sonst Sternen.
In der Umlaufbahn gibt es einen Erdensensor?
Für die Satelliten, die um die Erde sind, ja, das können sie haben, das hilft. Das ist ein großes Ding da unten und ziemlich.
Das hilft bei den großen Abständen nicht viel. Jetzt muss ich aber kurz zurück zu dem Launch. Wie bringt man diesen Satelliten überhaupt auf den Weg? Würde der Satelliten nichts tun, dann würde er ja irgendwann vielleicht einfach wieder runterfallen. Er muss sich quasi aus eigener Kraft dann noch dem...
Ja, die dritte Stufe von dieser Rakete, das hieß, Mars Express wurde mit einem Soyuz-Rakete gestartet, aber da war ein dritter oder vierter Etage, das heißt Fregat, und dieser Fregat hat uns auf die richtige Umlaufbahn gebracht, Richtung Mars, also der Mars Express war noch auf diesem Modul, war einmal um die Erde und zum richtigen Zeitpunkt Richtung Mars, oder eher Richtung wo Mars sein werde in sechs, in sieben Monaten, hat der Fregat wieder funktioniert und uns so aus der Erde...
Der Ätzen Stoß gegeben, und dann hat man als Erdsperefeld sozusagen verlassen.
Aber nicht direkt zu dem Punkt, wo der Mars sein soll, nur einen Millionen Kilometer entfernt von diesem Punkt. Weißt du warum? Wegen Planetary Protection. Wir müssen auch die andere Planeten beschützen von unserem Schrott. Falls wir denn die Kontrolle über Mars Express verloren hätten, es kann passieren, dass ein Satelliten so blind und taub wird, dann sollte er nicht auf den Mars crushen. Er sollte einfach vorbeifliegen und sich ins All verlieren. Deswegen darf man nicht direkt zu einem Planeten ins All starten, nur ein bisschen daneben.
Etwa in die richtige Richtung.
Und dann mit dem Streifstoff und mit dem Treibraketen am Bord des Satelliten so eine kleine Korrektur machen, ziemlich früh, damit es wenig Streifstoff kostet, aber auch ziemlich spät, damit man sicher ist, dass man danach den Satelliten nicht verliert.
Ah ja, verstehe. Und wann wurde diese Maßnahme gemacht ungefähr?
Also die letzte, das waren so die letzten paar Wochen vor der Ankunft.
Also es gab mehrere Korrekturen?
Ja, es gab mehrere Korrekturen in den sieben Monaten. Und die vorletzte war also ein paar Wochen vor der Ankunft von Mars. Und eigentlich das war nicht zu dem Punkt, wo wir in Marsumlaufbahn gehen sollten, aber das war, wo der Länder, weil wir hatten auch ein Länder, auf dem Mars landen sollte. Das heißt, für eine Weile waren wir doch auf einem Crashkurs in Richtung Mars. Und in den letzten paar Tagen vor der Ankunft an Mars haben wir dieses Länder abtrennen müssen von Mars Express und dann den Mars Express wieder aus diesem Crashkurs wegnehmen, damit er zu diesem Punkt in der Nähe von Mars, ein paar hundert Kilometer höher als die Oberfläche, aber nicht auf dem Mars so vorbeifliegen könnte. Und an diesem Punkt haben wir gebremst, damit der Planet den Satelliten so fängt.
Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, was die Mars Express Mission ursprünglich alles für Ziele hatte. Also es bestand aus zwei Teilen. Einem Hauptteil, der später eben als Satellit um den Mars herumfliegt und dort eben Aufnahmen macht, eine Beobachtung macht. Das hat ja auch soweit funktioniert. Und dann gab es noch ein Modul, was auf der Mars-Oberfläche landen sollte, der Beagle.
Der Beagle 2.
Der hat es aber nicht geschafft. Oder vielleicht hat er es geschafft, aber man weiß es nicht.
Man weiß es nicht. Wir haben es abgetrennt. Wir haben sogar ein Bild davon gemacht. Wir wissen, dass es so Richtung Mars zu dem richtigen Zeitpunkt gefahren ist. Und danach, also fünf Tage danach, als er so landen sollte und Signale funken zu den Satelliten um den Mars oder zurück zur Erde.
Der hat jetzt während dieser fünf Tage auch nicht gefunkt.
Das war so in dem Design. Und man hat danach gesagt, ja, das ist doch vielleicht ein Designfehler. Weil wir wissen nicht, wenn das große Fehler oder das Problem passiert ist. Also auf alle Länders, die wir jetzt machen, es ist eine Pflicht, dass die sich doch melden können. Auch während der Entry, Descending, Lending, also während dieser sehr heißen Phase, wo sie durch die Atmosphäre antreten, da müssen sie die Länders doch ein bisschen Telemetrie, also ein paar Daten hochschicken. Das war nicht geplant. Geplant war nur Telemetrie nach dem Aufklappen, auch auf dem Marsu von Solargeneratoren und kleinen Antänen und alles. Wenn man so ein Video davon sieht, man denkt ja, das ist alles schön, aber wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert, das war's.
Dann war's das. Jetzt haben wir mal eben sieben Monate übersprungen. In dieser Zeit muss ja im Prinzip permanent Kontakt gehalten werden mit diesem Gerät. Dafür benutzt man aber natürlich nicht mehr den Raum, in dem der Launch durchgeführt wurde, sondern dafür gibt es dann nochmal einen eigenen Raum. Oder gibt es da so universelle Räume, mit denen man alle Missionen steuert? Oder hat jeder da seinen eigenen Raum?
Okay, wir sind dann nach ein paar Tagen nach dem Start, wir sind umgezogen zu unserem Dedicated Control Room, also zu dem Mars Express Raum. Und eigentlich, das ist auch mit anderen Satelliten jetzt ein Raum für drei, weil Mars Express, Venus Express und Rosetta werden von diesem Raum gesteuert. Aber damals gab es nur Mars Express. Und da haben wir die ungefähr sechs Monate der Kreuzfahrt, wie es heißt, die Kreuzphase erlebt. Und in den letzten Monaten vor der Ankunft haben wir wieder angefangen in dem Hauptkontrollraum für ein neues Simulationsprogramm für die Ankunft. Weil das musste auch geübt werden. Es waren auch Kommandos, Befehle zu vorbereiten und so weiter. Und wir hatten dann zwei Satelliten zu fliegen, prinzipiell der echte von unserem Kontrollraum. Der hatte auch seine Probleme auf dem Weg. Und der falsche, also der Simulator, zweimal in der Woche von dem Hauptkontrollraum. Wir müssen auch wieder zwei Teams trainieren für die Ankunftsphase.
Aber in gewisser Hinsicht ist das schon ein großer Vorteil, dass man so eine Plattform hat, die vollkommen unterschiedliche Missionen durchführt, aber wo eben so große technische Ähnlichkeiten sind, dass eben viel des Wissens übertragbar ist.
Ja, das war natürlich ein Vorteil für diese Simulation von dem zweiten Simulationsprogramm. Wir wussten schon viel mehr über den echten Satelliten. Das war natürlich ein Vorteil. Und wir haben auch die Ankunft so vorbereitet, dass es den kleinen Problemen des echten Satelliten entspricht.
Das heißt, es gibt diesen speziellen Raum für Mars Express, der dann eben auch für andere Missionen mitverwendet wurde. Aber das ist eigentlich sozusagen die Bedingung. Wenn man ausgehend von der technischen Plattform, die man verwendet, braucht man einfach einen permanenten Ort für diese Mission. Anders lässt sich das nicht machen. Und darüber wird dann eben permanent Kontakt gehalten. Heißt das, dass man wirklich permanent Kontakt hat? Oder meldet sich dann die Sonne nur einmal die Woche und sagt, alles prima?
Jener Mission, also wie wir das planen. Für eine Mission, in einer Phase, wo wenig passiert, wie für Rosetta in der Kreuzfahrt. Und die Kreuzfahrt von Rosetta ist sehr lang, mehrere Jahre. Dann einmal der Woche ist genug. Das ist so geplant und vorprogrammiert.
Das spart ja auch Energie.
Das spart Zeit, das spart Leute, das spart Geld, das spart... Das spart. Energie ist in dem Fall vielleicht das kleinste Problem, wenn das Solarenergie ist. Aber für Mars Express, besonders für eine 7 Monate Reise und mit diesem kleinen Anfangsproblem, da war ein Kontakt jeden Tag. Mit einem Bodenstation. Und rund um die Uhr, around the clock, das war nur die letzte paar Wochen. Oder die letzten 12 Tage, da hat man den Satelliten permanent überwacht und gewartet und vorprogrammiert für die Ankunft an Mars. Auch diese 24 Stunden am Tag Überwahrung, das kostet auch viel Geld und kann man nur machen, wenn es wieder zu einer kritischen Phase kommt.
Okay, das heißt, diese Phase ist im Wesentlichen eine Überwachungsphase. Man stellt einfach sicher, dass noch alles super ist. Und von Zeit zu Zeit muss man eben den Kurs korrigieren, um langsam den richtigen Pfad einzunehmen. Und irgendwann muss man ja dann auch wirklich mal den Mars ansteuern, weil dann kann man sich auch sicher sein, dass das Ding jetzt unter Kontrolle ist. Was für Laufzeiten muss man da jetzt schon in Griff kriegen? Also da ist das Signal ja wahrscheinlich schon eine Weile unterwegs.
Ja, wenn wir am Mars angekommen sind, war die Entfernung so eine Astronomical Unit. Das ist einmal die Entfernung zur Sonne. Das heißt, acht Minuten ein Weg, also 16 Minuten hin und zurück. 16 Minuten. Maximal ist das, wenn Mars fast hinter der Sonne ist. Das sind ungefähr 400 Millionen Kilometer. Und da sind 20 bis 22 Minuten ein Weg. Also im Moment ist der Mars ziemlich weit. Das sind fast 40 Minuten hin und zurück.
Aber in dem Moment des Anflugs hat man natürlich eine Konstellation gewählt, wo der Mars möglichst nah dran ist, dass man nicht so lange hinfliegen muss.
Genau, das passiert jedes 26 Monaten so ungefähr. Weil jedes 26 Monate sind die Sonne, die Erde und der Mars so auf einer Linie. Und wenn man so drei bis vier Monate vor diesem Zeitpunkt zu dem Mars fliegt, dann kann man so drei bis vier Monate nach diesem Zeitpunkt ankommen. Und da ist die Reise die kürzeste.
Ah, ok.
So sechs, sieben Monate.
Und das wurde bei Mars Express sozusagen auch optimal genutzt.
Ja, und 2003 war auch eine historische Gelegenheit, wo es noch näher war, weil andere Parameter so an sich ändern. Und wenn du dich erinnerst, also im August, 27. August 2003, weil diese sogenannte Opposition oder Konjunktion jetzt noch heißt, und der Mars war sehr groß in dem Himmel, nicht so groß wie der Mond natürlich, aber das sieht man nicht mehr vor 6000 Jahren, so nah war er. Also das war eine sehr kurze Strecke. Und das war auch sehr wichtig für uns, weil Soyuz, das ist eine sehr schöne Rakete, aber nicht sehr stark. Und Mars Express hat umso mehr Treibstoff mitnehmen dürfen, weil die Trägerrakete brauchten auch nicht so viel Schub geben.
Das war ja auch der Grund, warum auch die Amerikaner dann auch geflogen sind.
Ja, 2003 war eine goldene Möglichkeit.
Da war dann einfach Mars-Time. Nicht ohne Erfolg, nicht wahr? Also auch die amerikanische Mission ist ja sehr gut, eigentlich sogar außerordentlich erfolgreich verlaufen, wenn man sich anschaut, wie lange die Roboter da schon auf dem Mars hin und her fahren.
Das ist sehr schön. Wir haben so mehr oder weniger zweimal im Jahr auch in Kontakt zu den Robotern, zu diesen Rovers gemacht durch Mars Express als Demonstration. Und das ist eigentlich der erste interplanetarische Netzwerk zwischen ESA und NASA. Okay, das stimmt. Nicht viel Daten zurückgeflogen, aber ein Bild hier, ein paar Kommandos da, und das ist natürlich sehr schön.
Ja, vielleicht wollen wir nochmal kurz erzählen, was die Aufgabe von Mars Express, also von dem Satellitenteil, genau ist. Es geht um die Erdbeobachtung, nicht die Erdbeobachtung, es geht um die Marsbeobachtung.
Ja und mehr. Er macht alles, was er kann.
Was kann er denn alles?
Wir haben nur einen Satelliten dort und der muss nämlich alles machen. Der soll die Atmosphäre untersuchen, den Boden und den Unterboden. Die Atmosphäre mit verschiedenen Spektrometern in verschiedenen Längen, Wellenlänge, den Boden mit Kamera und auch Spektrometer für Infrarot und so weiter und den Unterboden mit einem Radar. Und das hat er alles. Aber dann, je nachdem der Jahreszeit, dann werden verschiedene Instrumente zusammen benutzt oder nicht. Zum Beispiel der Radar funktioniert besser, wenn es auf dem Boden Nacht ist, weil die Radarwellen nicht von der Ionosphäre reflektiert sind und sie tiefer in den Boden gehen können. Also Nachtzeit ist für den Radar besser, natürlich nicht für die Kamera. Für die hohe auflösende Kamera will man Tageslicht haben. Also die ergänzen sich sehr gut. Und für die anderen, die können funktionieren, je nach Jahreszeit, aber auch je nach Breitengrad. Weil es gibt Sonnen von Mars, die interessanter sind als andere. Die Polen zum Beispiel sind sehr interessant, weil man sieht dort die Eisschichte. Und wie dieses Eis sich entwickelt, verschwindet im Sommer oder geht zu den anderen Seiten. Oder wird größer, kleiner. Das ist für die Wissenschaftler sehr interessant. Und Mars Express mit diesem Spektrometer Omega war der erste, der das Wasser gezeigt hat. Und mit dem Radar hat er gezeigt, dass die Polarkappen fast aus pures Wassereis bestehen.
Das heißt, Mars Express war eigentlich das erste Gerät, das tatsächlich nachgewiesen hat, dass Eis auf dem Mars vorhanden ist.
Ja, das war natürlich von vorher so vermutet. Und mit so thermalen Modellen, von Beobachtungen der amerikanischen Sonden, dass man so auch indirekt demonstrieren können. Aber da mit dem Spektrometer hat man gesehen, ja, da ist Wassereis. Da kann man sehr gut unterscheiden, was für Eis von CO2 ist. Das ist auch, aber nur auf der Oberfläche. Und mit dem Radar, der so tief bis 5 Kilometer unter der Oberfläche gucken kann. Ja, sehr tief. Der hat eine sehr große Wellenlänge, 100 Meter oder so, aber kann bis 5 Kilometer gehen. Nicht sehr akkurat, aber sehr tief. Und der hat so die Eiskappe sehr, sehr akkurat messen können, weil er kann die untere Schicht, die Schnittstelle zwischen Mars und Eis sehen können. Das sind 3,7 Kilometer am Nordpol.
Das heißt, es gibt nicht nur Eis, sondern es gibt richtig viel Eis.
Ja, viel Eis. Im Vergleich zu der Erde ist das Wasser auf dem Mars sehr wenig. Und Mars ist zweimal kleiner als die Erde. Wenn das ganze Wasser von den Polarkappen von Mars auf einem globalen Ozean wäre, das wäre 50 Meter Wasser auf dem Mars.
15 Meter tief.
Ja, 15 Meter tief. Und im Durchschnitt auf der Erde, das sind 2000 Meter. Und auch ohne unsere Polarkappen, nur durch den Ozeanen der Erde. Also das ist nicht vergleichbar in der Menge von Wasser. Aber Mars hat nur so gefrorenes Wasser und hatte wahrscheinlich, sehr wahrscheinlich in der frühen, in der ersten Zeit in seiner Existenz, viel mehr Wasser. Viel, viel mehr. In den ersten 500 Millionen Jahren. Und wahrscheinlich auch ein globales Ozean. Aber das ist schon dreieinhalb Millionen Jahre her. Milliarden Jahre her.
Und das Wasser ist dann einfach in die Atmosphäre und ins All verdampft?
Ja, denkt man. Weil die erste Energiequelle von einem Planeten ist nicht die Sonne, wie man es denken könnte, aber die interne Radioaktivität. Und Mars war kleiner, ist noch kleiner. Und das hat sich wahrscheinlich schneller erschöpft, die Radioaktivität. Und dann ist in dem Mars die Flüssigkeit in unserem Erden das Kern flüssig. Also die Flüssigkeit, das flüssiges Eisen ist fest geworden, dann gab es kein magnetisches Feld mehr. Und das magnetische Feld schützt die Atmosphäre von einem Planeten. Also sehr kurz zusammengefasst, aber das ist die Idee. Und deswegen, wenn es Wasser und es gab Wasser, dafür haben wir auch Beweise auf dem Mars gehabt, vor dreieinhalb Milliarden Jahren, dann seitdem ist es ganz trocken.
Es kommt sozusagen ein bisschen zu spät, um den ganzen Badespaß da ausleben zu können.
Ja, aber dafür haben wir eine Planete ohne Erosion. Und wenn man lebenden Stehensbedingungen verstehen will, das ist besser auf dem Mars als auf der Erde. Auf der Erde wird die Erosion durchs Wasser alle alten Seiten unserer Geschichte wegwischen. Und auf dem Mars ist es noch wie es war.
Alles schön erhalten sozusagen. Das heißt, Mars Express ist jetzt 2003 gestartet, war ein bisschen weniger als ein Jahr unterwegs. 2004, das heißt, er ist jetzt seit sechs Jahren im Betrieb. Und der freut sich auch noch bester Gesundheit.
Ja, wir freuen uns drauf. Und das funktionieren alle Instrumente noch. Funktioniert alles. Ab und zu eine Kleinigkeit, aber das sind generell so kleine wie bei Maschinen, die viele Computer an Bord haben, Netzwerke. Ein kleines Glitch, was vorübergehendes. Und man macht ein Reboot oder ein Reset und das geht weiter. Das ist nichts Besonderes.
War das auch erwartet, dass das so lange läuft?
Die Mission war für ein Marsjahr geplant, mit Treibstoff für zwei. Also das heißt für zwei Jahre von der Erde und mit Treibstoff für vier. Also seit 2005 könnte die Mission schon zu Ende sein. Wahnsinn, wir haben schon fünf Jahre Länge überlebt als erweitert.
Und was denkt man, wie lange der Treibstoff noch hält?
Also wir benutzen sehr wenig, so ein Drittelgramm am Tag. Und wir haben noch mindestens vier Kilos. Also Treibstoff, wenn wir keinen Rechnungsfehler gemacht haben, da haben wir für Jahrzehnte.
Was heißt, solange das Ding jetzt nicht einfach durch die Umwelteinflüsse sozusagen Schaden nimmt, kann es auch sein, dass der noch sehr, sehr, sehr lange weiterläuft?
Könnte sein. Es gibt natürlich Limiting-Factors, also sowas, was das Leben von so einem Ding limitiert. Okay, es könnte auch Fehler zu jeder Zeit antreten natürlich. Aber elektronische Geräte sind stabil. Das ist kein Problem. Die Batterien, wir benutzen und wir brauchen diese Batterien. Es gibt Finsternisse, nicht das ganze Jahr, aber 70 Prozent des Jahres gibt es Finsternisse. Und in diesen Finsternissen benutzt man die Batterien. So, also die werden ausgeladen, so wenig wie wir das können, weil wir wollen natürlich die Batterien so bestens schützen. Aber die Wissenschaftler, die wollen auch was machen, während oder kurz nach der Finsternisse. Und wir können nicht sagen, wir machen nichts jahrelang, weil wir wollen die Batterien schützen. Sonst, wozu eine Mission dort? Das wäre ein Kompromiss.
Aber das ist jetzt sozusagen auch ein interessanter Punkt, das ist ja vorhin auch schon rausgekommen. Man stellt sich das immer so vor, na ja, man hat da sozusagen die Mission, alles ist vorprogrammiert, dann fliegt das Ding dahin, führt das Ganze durch und fertig. Tatsächlich ist das Ganze ja viel dynamischer. Man ist jetzt erstmal da, viele Dinge mögen sich auf dem Flug dahin auch schon geändert haben, was man tun kann oder was man dann doch vielleicht tun kann, obwohl man dachte, das geht nicht. Und dann entstehen ja natürlich auch bei den Wissenschaftlern wahrscheinlich neue Bedürfnisse, auch auf Basis einfach der fortschreitenden wissenschaftlichen Forschung. Also dass einfach neue Fragen aufkommen, die beantwortet werden sollen, wo man dann sieht, aha, okay, wir haben ja noch Mars Express, da könnte man ja mal nachschauen.
Ja, das ist genau so, also zum Beispiel diese Wassergeschichte. Es ist viel auch mit den amerikanischen Sonden gefunden worden. Und jetzt wollen die Wissenschaftler wieder an der selben Stelle gucken, in anderen Jahreszeiten. Oder auch, was noch besser wäre, wenn MSL, so eine Mars Surface Laboratory, ein großes Auto, von der NASA auf den Mars 2012 landet. Da wollen die Wissenschaftler eine gemeinsame Beobachtung machen, mit dem MSL auf dem Boden und dem Mars Express oben. Und die können so zum gleichen Zeitpunkt, zum Beispiel, die Atmosphäre gucken. Oder das selbe Teil der Oberfläche. Der Hover guckt nur natürlich sehr lokal. Und der Mars Express oder andere Satelliten können auch die Big Picture, also global, gucken, in welchem geologischen Umgebung zum Beispiel der Hover sich befindet. Und das ergänzt sich prima.
2012 soll das landen?
Ja, soll in einem Jahr gerade, genau in einem Jahr, die Erde verlassen. Also Oktober, November 2011 und August 2012 ungefähr landen. Diese MSN ist richtig groß, ist groß wie ein Smart-Auto. Und hat sehr viele schöne Instrumente und Kameras und alles. Also das ist doch eine tolle Mission von der NASA. Und das soll landen mit einem ganz neuen Konzept, Sky Crane. Das heißt, die Triebraketten sind nicht unter diesem Ding, die sind oben unter einer kleinen Plattform, wie ein Kran. Und das Kran hat so einen Schnur mit dem Rover, der wird ganz sanft von diesem Sky Crane heruntergelassen. Und dann fliegt dieser Kran ein bisschen weit und wird runterfallen, soweit wie möglich.
Das heißt, man muss nicht diesen vollen Impact des Sturzes auffangen?
Nein, es gibt natürlich Thermal Shields, also man muss schon durch die Atmosphäre kommen. Aber in der Atmosphäre, dann für die letzten paar 100 Meter oder mehr, dann funktioniert dieses Ding. Also es ist ein bisschen wie Apollo sozusagen, nur die 3 Rakete sind unten und oben. Das ist so ein schönes Konzept.
Pöffig. Und dann kommen auch wieder neue Anforderungen an Operations, weil das ja auch alles sehr dynamisch ist, da kann irgendwelche Dinge auftreten. War es nicht auch so, hat der Mars Express nicht sogar auch ein Foto gemacht von den Rover?
Ne, unsere Auflösung von den Spuren, das können nur die Amerikaner, die haben auch Orbiters um den Mars und Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter, MRO, hat eine sehr, sehr starke auflösende Kamera, kann so Dinge, die ein paar Zentimeter groß sind, oder 30 Zentimeter, die können die Spuren sehen. Wir könnten das nicht. Unsere bessere Auflösung ist so 1 bis 2 Meter. Also man könnte vielleicht ein Pixel in ein Pixel ein Rover haben, aber das ist sehr hoch, unwahrscheinlich. Mars Express ist mehr, also seine Hochauflösung oder seine Aufgabe geht mehr in Richtung von mittleren Feldern. Also der kann gleichzeitig 60 Kilometer oder mehr, 60 Kilometer breit sehen. Also für Geologie, das ist sehr gut für solche Breite, solche Größe.
Was für Anforderungen kommen denn jetzt rein von den Wissenschaftlern? Mars Express dreht sich nach wie vor, kann tief gucken, kann mit zahlreichen Instrumenten die Oberfläche abscannen. Was sind so unerwartete Dinge, die dann herangetragen werden oder auch erwartete Anforderungen und was muss dann getan werden?
Also wissenschaftlich, man hat noch andere Sachen zu gucken. Eine sehr interessante ist der Mond Phobos. Mars hat zwei Monde, viel kleiner als unsere. Und Phobos ist sehr interessant, weil keiner weiß, wo er das kommt. Der sieht so aus wie ein Asteroid, aber der hat so eine ganz kreisförmige Umlaufbahn und kein Asteroid würde eine so umlaufbare, eine kreisförmige Umlaufbahn erreichen, weil das würde viel zu viel Energie brauchen, wenn wir schon mit einer ganz kleinen Sonde eine Runde Umlaufbahn erreichen wollen. Das kostet sehr viel Streifstoff. Also die Geometrie, wenn es ein gefangener Asteroid wäre, die Geometrie, das passt nicht alles.
Also man würde erwarten, dass er sozusagen irgendwie schlingert. Das ist irgendwie genauso unregelmäßig wie das Gravitationsfeld.
Ja, das ist einfach eine Ellipse, aber das geht sehr hoch und dann zurück und so weiter. Nicht rund. Und Mars hat sogar einen zweiten Mond, ein bisschen kleiner und weiter entfernt, Deimos. Und er ist genauso auch auf einer Runde Umlaufbahn. Also dass das Ding einmal passiert ist, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich. Und zweimal ist quasi unmöglich. Also man denkt ja, woher kommt das? Und die Leute sagen, wenn Mars so entstanden ist, dann waren so wie die Ringe von Saturn oder so, waren so Stücke, die nicht, die um den Mars waren. Vielleicht ein Ring. Und das hat sich zusammengebaut und hat so ein Mini-Planet oder einen Mini-Mond gemacht. Nur die Beschaffenheit, also wie wir das wissen, von Mars und Phobos, die entsprechen sich schlecht. Also wenn es ein Stück von Mars wäre, dann wäre die Farbe einfach, die Zusammensetzung wäre gleich. Und sie nicht gleich. Und noch schlimmer, der Phobos, man kann schon wissen, mit welchen Steinen das gemacht ist. Und man kann es messen, man kennt den Volumen, man kennt die Masse, und der ist zu leicht. Da fehlen 30 Prozent der Masse. Der ist einfach zu leicht. Das ist schon ziemlich lange bekannt oder vermutet. 1964 oder so hatten sogar Advisor von dem amerikanischen Präsident gesagt, das ist vielleicht so ein Spaceship. Auf Internet gibt es viele Geschichten, das ist ein Spaceship.
Der Todesstern.
Wenn Rosetta und Lutetia vorbeifflogen, vor ein paar Monaten jetzt, und Lutetia sieht sehr ähnlich wie Phobos, dann haben die Leute gesagt, die sind ja nicht verrückte. Ja, und die sind wahrscheinlich aus der selben Fabrik. Also die bessere Theorie, aber das bleibt noch zu demonstrieren, ist, wie für unseren Mund auch, eigentlich ein sehr großer Impact, ist irgendwann von einem großen Asteroid auf dem Mars. Und dann sind ein paar Stücke wieder in die Umlaufbahn von Mars so hochgesprungen und haben sich zusammen so kollabiert. Irgendwie. Aber drinnen gibt es nur Löcher, weil die Gravitationsfeld war zu dünn und das könnte nicht richtig schmelzen. Und dann sind noch, ja, Hölle drin, Löcher. Und deswegen entspricht der Maß und Volumen nicht.
Super. Das sind dann so diese Dinge, die man auch aus Science-Fiction-Filmen kennt, wo dann so irgendwelche Schlangen und Drachen wieder in Löchern drin sind.
Umso wichtiger ist diese Phobos-Grundmischung von den Russen. Das ist schön, weil die wollen ein Stück von Phobos zu der Erde zurückbringen. Und die starten auch in einem Jahr, wenn sie fertig sind. Das ist auch verschoben worden. Aber hoffentlich sind sie fertig und sie werden ein Stück von Phobos zu der Erde zurückbringen in drei, vier Jahren, wenn alles klappt.
Das ist aber doch besonders aufwendig, dann wieder zurückzukehren.
Ja, aber viel weniger von Phobos als von Mars, weil das Gravitationsfeld ist zu klein. Das ist der Trick.
Jetzt haben wir viel über Mars Express geredet, das ist auch alles super spannend und wichtig. Aber was jetzt den Bereich Operations betrifft, sind ja die Erdbeobachtungsmissionen zum Beispiel genauso vorhanden und müssen ja auch regelmäßig betreut werden. Und die erfordern ja wahrscheinlich auch eine ganz andere Aufmerksamkeit, weil man natürlich da, weiß nicht, mehr Daten sammelt oder häufiger holen kann. Macht das mehr Arbeit?
Ja, das Operations-Profile, wie das funktioniert, das ist ganz anders als bei einer interplanetarischen Mission. Zum Beispiel diese Satelliten von der Erdbeobachtung sind sehr niedrig, so ein paar hundert Kilometer über die Oberfläche der Erde. Und das heißt, die fliegen sehr schnell. Und man sieht die nur ein paar Minuten, sieben bis zwölf oder fünfzehn Minuten. Und man hat nicht so stundenlang Zeit, um was zu gucken und alles. Man muss so sehr schnell prüfen, ob alles klappt und dann die Kommandos für die nächsten Beobachtungen hochschicken. Und schon ist er wieder weg. Deswegen haben sie entwickelt und sie benutzen das jetzt auch so Automationsysteme, die noch schneller als Menschen, die den Zustand der Satelliten so schätzen können. Und das macht für diese Mission natürlich Sinn, diese Automation.
Wie viele Satelliten werden hier derzeit von ESOC aus überhaupt kontrolliert? Wie viele Missionen insgesamt?
Wie viele Missionen? So ungefähr 11 oder 12 würde ich sagen.
Und davon machen die Erdbeobachtungen wie viel aus?
So eine kleine Hälfte.
Und dann kommen die Weltraumteleskope, Astronomie, Projekte.
Und der Planetarische.
Wobei das ist?
Drei und nun drei oder vier, also jede. Und alles zusammen macht zwölf.
Also Venus Express, Mars Express und Rosetta sind drei. Das heißt, dafür hat man einfach einen ganz anderen Rhythmus für die Erdbeobachtung unseres Liedes. Das ist sehr viel mehr Daily Operation als das jetzt bei den interplanetarischen Missionen der Fall ist.
Ja, und die Daten können nicht nur auf einen Bodenstation empfangen werden. Sie haben auch mehrere Stationen um der Welt, um die Daten in Real-Time zu schicken, generell. Also das ist auch ein großer Unterschied zu uns. Also bei uns haben wir einen Speicher und wir machen Beobachtungen und dann wird das zu Erde gefunkt und zurück und so weiter.
Wenn es fertig ist.
Wenn es fertig ist. Also für die Erdbeobachtung, aber auch für Astronomie, je nachdem, es gibt auch andere hybride Lösungen, aber am Anfang waren alle Satelliten Real-Time. Die haben so gefunkt, die Daten, die sie zur selben Zeit gesammelt haben.
In dem Moment, wo sie sich gesammelt haben.
Und dafür brauchst du eine Bodenstation.
Klar, sonst ist ja alles wieder weg. Aber so richtig viel zwischenspeichern können die ja auch nicht, weil das sind ja auch nicht wenig Daten, die anfangen.
Ja, genau, das ist vielleicht auch ein großer Unterschied, weil von Erdbeobachtung mit so vielen Instrumenten wie auf Envisat und so, das wäre viel zu viel Daten, um alles zu speichern. Beim Interplanetary, bei interplanetarischer Mission, das Ding ist so weit, du kannst sowieso nicht sehr viel zurück funken, dann brauchst du nicht viel speichern und dann müssen schon die Instrumente vom Anfang an die Daten komprimieren oder schön so verarbeiten an Bord. Zum Beispiel bei unserem Radar, hier auf der Erde, so wie die Radar von Envisat und so, die erzeugen sehr, sehr viel Daten. Und auf dem Mars Express war das nicht möglich. Das ist schon verarbeitet an Bord und nur die Ergebnisse zurückgefunkt.
Wie viel Daten könnte man denn überhaupt maximal herunterbekommen? Von wo? Von den Erdbeobachtungstateliten.
Oh ja, die sind in den mehrere Megabits Bereich. Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Mehrere Megabit pro Sekunde.
Also das sind schon viele Daten.
Und vor allem sehr rohe Daten.
Ja, viele, viele Daten. Dafür haben sie auch sehr große Datenvorarbeitungszentren. Esrin in Italien ist auch.
Aber was machen denn die Satelliten, wenn sie ihre Datenmenge mal nicht loswerden? Wenn es jetzt keine erfolgreiche Kommunikation gibt.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach verloren.
Dann müssen sie die wegschmeißen.
Ja, die gehen zum nichts. Das passiert mit jedem Satelliten. Wenn eine Funkkommunikation vorgesehen ist und die Daten werden geschickt, dann das war's.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ihr könnt ja zumindest für eine Rotation genug Puffer haben.
Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Okay, das hängt dann auch von der jeweiligen Mission.
Und wie viel Daten das ist. Bei unseren Missionen können wir ein paar Prozente speichern und versuchen wieder zur Erde zu schicken. Aber wenn wir mehrere Stunden Kommunikation verlieren, können wir das nicht alles wiederkriegen.
Das ist aber bei den Interplanetarischen anders. Da probiert man dann das Ergebnis so lange zu funken, bis man es dann auch hat.
Ja, aber die Bandbreite ist entsprechend kleiner. Und Bodenkontakt kostet viel mehr, weil die Bodenstationen größer sind. Man kann auch nur ein paar Prozente von den Daten wieder zu Erde zu funken, zweimal. In unserem Fall, das ist das zweite Mal.
Wie gut ist denn die Mobilfunkverbindung zum Mars?
Ganz gut, ganz gut. Je nach dem Wetter, deswegen bauen wir Bodenstationen hier in Trocken.
Also Wetter auf der Erde.
Wetter auf der Erde, ja. Weil in X-Band, also wenn es stark regnet, dann wird der Signal sehr arm und man kann generell die Telemetrie nicht mehr kriegen. Also man sieht nur das Signal, aber nicht die Daten. Aber das ist selten. Aber bei großen, dicken, schwarzen Wolken oder Gewitter über einen Bodenstation, dann das war's. Wir kriegen keine Daten. Aber in New Norcia, in Australien, wo unsere australische Podestation ist, in Cebreros bei Madrid und in Malarga, in Argentinien, dann ist generell das Wetter sehr schön und sehr trocken. Und dann hat man diese Erdwetterprobleme nur sehr selten. Aber wenn es schlechtes Wetter ist, dann ist es einfach so.
Und die Sonne, spielt die da auch eine Rolle?
Ja, das ist Sonnenwetter, also Weltraumwetter. Einfluss ist auf der Kommunikation und auch auf der Computer an Bord. Weil wir sind nicht am Mars von irgendwas beschützt, nur wenn der Satelliten hinter dem Mars ist. Also beim schlechten Sonnenwetter, also wenn die Sonne sehr aktiv ist, dann kriegt man sehr viele Fehler auf die Computers. Das haben wir, weil die Sonne so ruhig war die letzten paar Jahre, das haben wir kaum erlebt. Nur, das war heute genau vor sieben Jahren auf dem Weg zum Mars, da gab es ein großes Coronal Mass Ejection, so eine große Sonne-Explosion. Und das hat die Satelliten auf der Erde beeinflusst. Es gab auch Probleme mit den Kommunikationssatelliten. Und an diesem Tag habe ich mit einer Mutter gesprochen. Sie hat gesagt, hast du Probleme mit der Mars-Sonde? Geh mal in die Küche, Mutti, wir haben keine Probleme. Wir sind nicht bei der Erde. Man muss immer seine Mutter zu gut zuhören. Weil ein paar Stunden später, als ich das Kontrollzentrum verlassen wollte, waren Leute da in dem Kontrollraum und ich wollte Tschüss sagen und habe gesagt, was ist denn da los? Und was los war, ist, dass die Star-Trackers, diese Konstellationskamera, nichts mehr erkennen, weil die Sonne-Explosion hatte den Mars, also den Sonnenwind, sagen wir mal, mit vielen Protonen, vielen, vielen Partikeln, hatte den Mars dann erreicht. Natürlich ein paar Stunden später als die Erde sechs oder zehn Stunden früher. Und da wusste der Satelliten nicht mehr, wo er war. Er hat nur Tausende von falschen Sternen geguckt. Und da natürlich auf beide Star-Trackers. Es gibt Fälle, wo die Redundancy, die Verdoppelung von alles, nicht hilft. Weil von der Umwelt, Sonnenumwelt in dem Fall, waren nur falsche Sterne zu sehen. Und 30 Stunden lang hat es gedauert, der Tsunami von Protonen.
Der Sonnensunami. Was ist denn, wenn die Erde und der Mars sozusagen hinter der Sonne verdeckt ist?
Hinter der Scheibe der Sonne ist er sehr selten. Aber auch jedes 26 Monate geht er ganz nah. Und für ein paar Wochen müssen wir die Mission unterbrechen. Für ein paar Tage ist Kommunikation kaum oder gar nicht möglich. Auch wenn er nicht hinter der Scheibe ist, aber nicht weit. Und für ein paar Wochen ist er nicht sehr sicher, weil falls wir ein Problem haben, dann gibt es auf dem Mars Express einen sogenannten Sicherheitsmodus. Dieser Sicherheitsmodus benutzt nicht die X-Band, sondern die S-Band, also 2 Gigahertz statt 8. Die Sonne ist eine große S-Band-Quelle, und dann sieht man nichts mehr. Also X-Band sieht man noch, nur ein paar Tage Unterbrechung, aber S-Band für Wochen ist nichts zu machen. Deswegen machen wir so wenig Operations wie möglich für 5 Wochen, weil wir wissen, in den 5 Wochen, wenn etwas Problematisches kommen würde, dann könnten wir nichts machen, weil der Satelliten allein in diesem Sicherheitsmodus überleben sollte. Er ist dafür designt. Wir können das prinzipiell, aber wir wollen das vermeiden, wenn wir können.
Das heißt, dann ist auch mal Urlaubsphase angelangt.
Das ist nicht für uns, nicht für dich. Ich hatte das das erste Mal gedacht, 2004, aber das ist nie so gewesen. Weil man kann in dieser Phase einen Bodencomputer, neue Software installieren oder andere Sachen machen, wofür man nie Zeit hat und so weiter. Und man macht auch so Tests, weil man will besser kennenlernen den Einfluss der Sonne auf unsere Sonden und auf die Kommunikation. Für die Zukunft, für die Wissenschaft, aber auch für die Zukunft der Operationen. In ein paar Jahren fliegt BepiColombo, nächste planetarische Mission, zu Planet Merkur. Merkur ist immer Sender an der Sonne, bei der Sonne. Unsere Kollegen von BepiColombo wollen wissen ganz genau, wie die Sonne diese Kommunikation beeinflusst. Und dafür sind alle in unserer Konjunktionsperiode so eine Möglichkeit, davon zu lernen.
Aber da wird dann sozusagen das Sonnenthema nochmal richtig krass, so nah an der Sonne dran. Kann man sich ja auch leicht verbrennen. Ja, super. Haben wir irgendwas ganz Wichtiges noch ausgelassen, was man im täglichen Operations-Alltag immer wieder eine Rolle spielt, über das wir jetzt noch nicht gesprochen haben?
Ja, vielleicht ein paar Worte zum Team-Geschichte. Weil diese Simulationskampagne vor dem Launch oder vor einer kritischen Phase, das hilft, ein Team zusammenzubringen. Und dann kommt die super heiße Phase mit Public Relations, alles was man findet, Wissenschaftler und alles. Aber das dauert nicht ewig. Irgendwann ist Schluss mit der Show und man muss so mit einem alltäglichen Alltag klarkommen. Das haben wir auch erfahren so 2004 und 2005, so ein paar Monate nach der Ankunft von dieser heißesten Phase, wenn es zu einer richtigen Routine kam. Obwohl auf Mars-Express-Routine ist nie so Routine, dass man alles automatisieren kann, weil es kommen immer so neue, keine Neuigkeiten. Und jetzt was können wir uns überhaupt noch sehen und riechen? Weil wenn man so auf einem Boot große Ereignisse erlebt hat, dann kommt doch die Routine des Betriebs. Damals hatten wir Seminare und Nachholungen von Team-Building. Dinge, die man normalerweise vor einer Mission macht, das hatten wir keine Zeit oder keine Idee davon gehabt. Das haben wir danach gemacht.
Um einfach die sozialen Strukturen zu stärken.
Ja, genau. Die soziale Kompetenz von den Leuten auch. Weil Superspezialisten können auch nicht die angenehmsten Leute der Welt sein. Und wenn es nur um Technik und ein Ziel zu erreichen, wenn nur das Ziel zählt, dann ist es okay. Man kann sagen, der oder die, die sind so. Macht nichts, die sind gut. Aber danach taucht das auf irgendwie. Und man muss auch arbeiten. Die Leute, auch ich, haben sehr viel davon gelernt. Von Miteinanderleben. Das ist auch sehr wichtig. Auch heute, wenn ein kleines Problem kommt, dann die Leute wissen, wer ist was, wer ist gut zu was. Und wollen nicht unbedingt sitzen auf ihren kleinen Spezialitätenfeld. Die sind viel mehr hilfsbereit und angenehm.
Aber was befördert das? Was muss man einbringen? Arbeitet man da in Paargruppen zusammen, sodass man auch immer mal wieder andere Bereiche mitbetreut, die man sonst nicht macht, um da mehr Verständnis zu gewinnen?
Ja, sowas. Am Anfang haben wir sogar Seminare mit professioneller Hilfe gemacht, wie Coaching oder psychologischer Hilfe, sagen wir mal, ein paar Mal natürlich, und dann uns selbst organisiert, auch damit die Kenntnisse durch das Team so besser verteilt werden und dass jedes Jahr ein paar, wie nennen das, Fokus, Mission Focuses, ein paar Stichwörter oder Ziele definiert werden sind zusammen. Und dann ein oder zwei Mal im Jahr gucken wir, ja, haben wir das erreicht. Und das sind Dinge, die ergänzen die Missionroutine. Die Missionroutine muss zuerst gemacht werden, ja natürlich für die Kunden, aber wir müssen auch andere Ziele haben, die wir selbst definieren und wofür wir Kontrolle haben und die Sinn machen für das Mission.
Stabil bleibt das Thema über Jahre? Ich meine, Leute werden auch mal ihren Arbeitsplatz wechseln wollen.
Gute Frage. Also ja, stabil schon. Das ändert sich peu à peu. Jedes Jahr werden ein oder zwei Leute ersetzt. Also seit dem Launch sind hier nur noch zwei oder drei von dem ehemaligen Team. Aber das sind schon sieben Jahre.
Und wie viele, also jetzt in Bezug auf Mars Express. Und wie viele Leute sind jetzt insgesamt in dem Team?
Also sieben sind zehn Ingenieure. Und die Leute, die in dem Kontrollraum sind, sind fünf Techniker, die Kontrolleure. Also die sind ein bisschen stabiler. Die Ingenieure, die wollen auch andere Missionen erleben. Und es ist auch gut, dass sie ihre Kenntnisse zu anderen, in unserem Fall planetarischen Missionen oder sogar ganz andere Familien von Missionen ihre Kenntnisse so beibringen.
Ja, Michel, ich würde sagen, dann können wir jetzt hier auch langsam mal alles zusammenpacken. Vielen Dank für die super spannenden, ausführlichen Informationen hier rund um Operations, das Kontrollieren von Missionen, wenn sie dann erstmal die Erde verlassen haben. Aber es gibt ja auch Arbeit schon vorher, wie wir gehört haben. Und vor allem eine ganze Menge danach.
Dann ich danke dir. Es war sehr, sehr spannend, auch für mich, auch wenn ich das schon wieder erlebt habe. Aber das ist immer schön. Das sind sehr, sehr, sehr gute Ereignisse. Auch eine Zukunft, das geht weiter.
Ja, und vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören ein weiteres Mal. Hier geht es auch bald wieder weiter mit weiteren Aspekten und Ausrissen hier aus der Raumfahrt. Danke fürs Zuhören und sage Tschüss und bis bald bis zum nächsten.